the big picture here is well it's a
relatively positive compared with last
time around I say compared with last
time around and also compared with
expectations but there are a few little
nuances that we'll get to in a second
These Bars just show you what was
expected last time and this is gross
domestic products it's the rate at which
the economy is growing the rate at which
we're all getting better off and
anything above the line obviously is
positive anything below the line is
negative look that one minus one point
four percent that was the recession that
was forecast last time around let's see
how those numbers change with the latest
forecasts look the red bars here that's
the latest forecasts okay this is the
key thing to look at to start off with
because obviously it was that question
of whether there was going to be a
recession well now the chancellor says
there isn't a technical recession what
does that mean in practice well a
technical recession is two successive
quarters where the economy is shrinking
in this case well look the economy is
basically down by 0.2 percent uh it's
not great by the scheme of things but
compared with last time around it's
certainly better better next year as
well but here's also something that's
interesting in the following years so
beyond the next election uh the forecast
is actually a little bit worse weaker
growth in those periods there how does
that impact public finances this is
really important because that determines
how much the chancellor potentially has
to spend versus his forecast and versus
his rules this is showing you public
sector net borrowing that's a sense of
GDP these were the numbers that we
jotted down during the actual speech
itself and as you can see again a bit
less borrowing each of these years so
he's borrowing a little bit less why is
that in large part it's because the
economy is doing better and when the
economy does better that means more in
the way of tax revenues coming in which
means that he doesn't necessarily uh
suffer as a result of that he actually
brings in cash and doesn't have to
borrow as much as a result but now let's
get on to the actual policies uh that
were announced today now this is very
big picture ultimate big pitch there's
something called the scorecard which
kind of tots up all of the different
policies and gives a sense of whether
that's money coming out of the exchequer
that's in negative terms or coming into
the executive tax Rises and this is
giveaways it is largely giveaways but
here's again something striking and
we're totting things up here so within
that chunk there you've got the full
expensing expenses a big deal there for
many businesses around the country
that's going to cost kind of getting
towards 10 billion pounds a year by
2024.25 but you've also got other things
as well you've got childcare you've got
those pensions uh plans as well the
changes to the pension plans or they're
mostly off in the uh off towards the
future full expensing the big thing in
the short run but also note the shape of
These Bars again for the next few years
you've got big giveaways coming up to 20
25 26 and then they diminish and that's
largely because that expensing is a
temporary thing it's a really big deal
but it's currently a temporary thing and
it's not necessarily going to be in the
future and of course this is after the
election so you've got big question
marks of what's about what's going to
happen after the election or any of
those things going to be renewed in the
next Manifesto but we'll bring you more
detail on how that you know the makeup
of those bars in a second if just one
other thing to note I do you have
hundreds of other charts but I'm going
to try and keep it relatively short this
time around real household disposable
income you know this this is perhaps the
ultimate way of getting a sense of that
kind of pound in your pocket impacts of
what we've been going through recently
anything above the bar shows we're
getting better off after you adjust for
inflation after you adjust for income
after you adjust all of those different
things and this is last time around look
look at this right hand side those two
bars are the lowest that they have ever
been okay last time around okay the red
bars there now look at the red bars
again and we're going to bring on these
latest updated numbers so improved
numbers look at the red bars
the fall is a little bit less isn't it
just over here I'll go back just so you
can do last time pretty bad this time
still pretty bad but not necessarily
quite as bad and actually that's still
the worst two years in modern record so
going back you can see it here there
have never been another two years going
back to the 1950s where we've had as big
a squeeze on our personal disposable
incomes as we are going through in the
next couple of years so still very tough
for many households around the country
but that's the interesting thing about
this budget was these numbers are now
finally starting to get better rather
than getting worse of course questions
remain as to whether that's politically
enough for the conservative party and as
I say you saw the numbers there in the
charts there when it came to the
scorecard when it came to growth when it
comes to public finances you know big
questions about how much of the pain is
going to be felt after the next election
and therefore raising the question about
what comes in a Manifesto